hello friends and welcome to another
game spot now playing i'm your host
daniel dwyer joined my mr infinity
himself john vanyaki hello everyone how
you doing my friend hi danny good to see
you nice to see you sean potten who's
going to be uh driving throughout the
next hour or so as we explore the
wonders of disney infinity
3.0 oh
oh my goodness it's been a crazy uh
journey for disney infinity it's been
around for is it two years now we're
coming up well this would be the third
version third version so this would be
three years now is the three well it's
2000 i guess it's not it was 2013. yeah
yeah you're right because the original
date was earlier than that but anyway
okay whatever you've you've clearly done
your homework or dwight
this year i've done here
don't because we have so much stuff to
get through today look at all these
ridiculous
star wars toys we're focusing on the
brand new uh playset which is something
that people have been asking for ever
since all this disney star wars stuff
happened ever right infinity's been
doing interviews with you last year
where you're like
ah marvel's cool but yeah you know so
next year what's gonna be star wars and
it's like uh just wait danny you know
that's infinite possibilities on the
platform so yeah this year uh the
obviously for those of you that are
watching that that aren't familiar with
infinity um
we've got uh a whole bunch of different
great characters from across the walt
disney company inside of disney infinity
and this year we've added a smattering
of characters from uh the star wars saga
spanning all the films as well as
animated series like star wars rebels
and um
this uh actually i think it's next week
what i forget what day it is is it still
it's september yes so it's still it's
it's what's december 16th september 16th
so i think it's at the end of september
uh i know it's at the end of september
the rise against the empire playset
which is uh playsets for those of you
that are watching are kind of like um
they're like standalone game experiences
inside of infinity we sell them for
34.99 if you do all the missions you
know for the completionist it's like
somewhere between like six to eight
hours worth of content the rise against
the empire place that tells the star
wars that we're familiar with and we
grew up with uh episodes four through
six yeah i've got one uh right here uh
for a frame of reference yeah here's
some you got two every starter every one
of these packs comes with uh two
characters male and a female male and
female right there yeah exactly so and
then um that little uh a translucent
piece there is what we call the playset
piece yeah and you put that one down in
order to gain access to
uh the the rise against the empire
places boots up like a stand-alone sort
of experience within the sort of general
toilet right which is why we call we
call infinity a platform which means
that um you know not only is a platform
for characters but it's a platform for
different types of games and game
experiences so um the star wars games
are largely
open world action adventure games and
then we put out uh inside out which is
based on pixar's new film and i know
you've been playing with sadness because
you saw some of your tweets i love my
sadness yeah exactly and so that
particular playset though is more of
like a 2d 2.5 d platformer um not really
focused on lightsaber combat and space
exploration
more focused on multiplayer and kind of
having fun together and what i love
about this when you boot up infinity 3.0
for the first time is you've got a sort
of uh a taste of of a bunch of them
starts you off in like there's a star
wars thing happening and then suddenly
you're playing as joy yeah we can we
could show that in a little bit if you
wanted to cool and then there was like a
cart racing uh yeah mickey mouse we had
uh yeah we brought on the guys from uh
sumo digital um that worked on i was a
huge fan of sonic and sega all-star
racing transform and so we brought them
on to lend their expertise to all the
different driving models that we have
inside of infinity and they also made a
kart racer for the game um which is what
that uh that we call it the toy box
speedway um so it's fun because you can
have like yoda riding in cinderella's
carriage uh in a track themed to
nightmare before christmas it's like a
true crazy mashup but the playsets which
is what sean's playing right now for
rise against the empire um these are
what we call true to property
experiences so we don't have the match
you're not going to see lightning
mcqueen driving around hoth um and it's
it's really the thing that i think it's
important for for game spot viewers that
are watching right now is that you know
we care a lot about trying to be true to
that property and true to the fans of
that property and so yeah like i get it
someone's probably making fun of me in
the chat right now saying like this
dude's scaling an ath and it's blue and
there's batteries like yeah okay we're
still a kids and family game you know if
you want the hardcore experience go play
battlefront which i'm sure is going to
be great but if you if you're a gamer
mom or gamer dad
infinity is a great way to introduce the
star wars that we grew up with you know
to your kids yeah i was playing through
it yesterday and like the the sort of
the cut scenes little animations in
between each level were like oh yeah
okay i understand what's happening
this is like if i was playing this with
my like imaginary soon to be born child
or suit future to be born child uh
it would be it's it's almost like
translating it to that sort of yeah like
yeah to that audience kind of the way
the lego games did i feel yeah
absolutely and those are incredible
experiences but what's fun about
infinity is that it is the only you know
game in this toys to life genre that
will have disney marvel uh star wars and
pixar inside of it so i think that
that's fun because it's you know there's
so many different things you can do with
all these different characters and we
had lightsaber combat this year and we
brought in the team from ninja theory
that had worked on heavenly sword and
slave to lend their expertise to
you know really making our combat inside
of infinity feel awesome
and uh right now actually sean's doing
the uh
the old wrap the toe cable around the
8080
that old chestnut experience um yeah one
of the things that you're pretty bad
i've also had
how many different experiences are there
within any one of these these packs
because uh when i was going through it
like it was level after level there was
a good variety um within each one as
well and then you can sort of like jump
into them
ad hoc as well yeah so basically the way
that the playsets work is you can
um they're they're intended to be like
standalone game experiences um and you
can jump in and play with different
characters uh from from the star wars
playsets it doesn't matter what era the
star wars characters are from you
collect these things called uh legacy
coins and that allows you then to play
with any star wars character
um not yet nice
yeah exactly i love that that's that's
my favorite part so you know right now
actually he has done that and now you
can see the atat actually has a remote
on its back
um playing up our because our entire um
conceit with infinity is that these
aren't the characters but rather the toy
versions of these characters and these
vehicles
and so um anyway in terms of going back
to your original question like tell me
about all the different types of
experiences inside out is is more of a
puzzle platformer the star wars
experiences are more open world action
adventure we just announced the what is
that atat doing we just announced the um
uh a new playset that we're doing for
marvel called marvel battlegrounds and
that will be a new genre of gameplay
experience as well so not only is a
platform for all these characters but
it's also a platform for different game
genres and as the company puts out
different films and different content
we're going to support all of those
things inside of infinity but do it in a
way that really makes sense to the to
the brand that's awesome did you just
pull that off the top of the att
yes i did well we were doing play
testing so the guys at studio gobo put
this together in brighton
we've worked with them for a long time
when we had um done testing with this it
was like hey you know what like atats
are really cool but driving one's not
that cool because of how slow and
lumbering they are and so they came up
with this concept that you know hey like
the old kenner toys of yesteryear um you
know we'll we'll actually instead put a
you know we'll use that as a design or
inspiration for the design but we're
going to put a remote on its back so
that people can actually pull the remote
far off to the side and then watch them
control kind of like battle bots from a
distance in fact after he's done with
this there's there's a atat fight that
we can do two players oh cool where we
control them separately and make them
fight against each other which is a lot
of fun and it is drop in dropout two
player as well yeah all this all these
experiences yeah and then our toy box
mode which is like the other half of
infinity um where you can build and
create levels and uh kind of make your
own games that one's uh up to four
players simultaneously online so two
player couch uh uh but four player
online and one of the things i love
about this is that like i i'm i'm one of
those gamers who enjoys collecting
things i enjoy unlocking things yeah
like one of the most addictive parts of
the the toybox experience especially
when it comes to like your house and
whatnot is like getting a little bit
better you started doing the house yeah
my house has got andy's room guys this
is so crazy for me to hear
danny o'dwyer talking about i mean
because we intend for this to be a game
for six to 12 year olds but what's
awesome is that guys like you like core
gamers are like yeah whatever i'm not
shame this is awesome like i'm having
fun with it too so you actually are
building your own home oh yeah i've got
my little friend room a little sidekick
room yeah i've got winnie the pooh in
there hanging out
it's so awesome one of the favorite
things i love is is actually
like in the game like playing one of
these and then like it says oh you've
unlocked this oh you've been like this
or even like this yeah and they're going
on man when i get back to my house right
i'm going to put that pinball machine in
there yeah i'm going to get that weird
yeah in there mcduck's gonna be so happy
with all the i was watching um uh
gerstmann and the giant bomb guys uh do
a quick look of it and they uh they
pulled up and they had there's the tron
arcade machine you can put in there and
he's like you should really just be able
to play it i mean i know it'd be tough
to do and i know probably wouldn't work
a licensing right you should really just
be able to play the original toronto
arcade game right now but it's funny
even to see them you know looking at it
too because it's um it's it's it's
become something that's okay for adults
to play too and um
i i love that the team loves that you
know we've always wanted to make
something that's
um good enough for for gamers like you
and i but also then accessible for kids
and we hope this year and anyone that's
watching that gets a chance to play i
agree that you know we've we've made it
mm-hmm it's the type of game that i wish
i could play with my nieces if they
weren't back in ireland
maybe maybe if you play online you could
play online i'd have to buy them a
playstation 4. that's not happening well
it's also available this feels like a
great time to plug well it's also
available on playstation 3 xbox 360 and
wii u if they have those systems they
don't oh they don't 3d accessories what
do they play with 3ds fortunately not
yet for the people who are watching uh
we've got a bunch of uh we've got two
packs for the rise against the empire
playset which we're going to be giving
away and we'll give you details on that
later on uh in the stream but keep your
eye on the gamespot twitter account i'll
say that oh there it is uh so what are
we going into now we've got some uh
we're gonna escape
of the uh yeah you know we're we're
equal gender
you know we actually like kind of pride
ourselves on that we like you know all
those playsets now come with both a
female and male character so uh you know
everyone has an opportunity to play as
their favorite character i was rocking
at leia and sadness uh last night with
my girlfriend as well were you really
he's good fun yeah we um so it's
interesting the when we take a look at
our demographics of who's actually
playing infinity this
infinity has become what is what is
known um in disney as like a four
quadrant property okay so it is
appealing to young and old which is
great but it's also appealing almost
evenly to male and female really and i
think that that's really great for our
industry as well right like you know
there's there's no reason why we
shouldn't be creating and um celebrating
strong female characters in all of our
games to attract more girls to know that
it's okay to play yeah especially
younger gamers yes that is instills a
sort of uh you're a part of us yeah well
like you know games are okay like it's
that's that's the thing and so um that's
why we always make sure we include a
male and a female and you know we
continue to do everything we can to to
broaden the amount of female characters
that we have inside of infinity and so
uh our starter package actually comes
with ahsoka tano um from the clone wars
animated series yeah she's we were
insistent that we needed a powerful
female jedi and so that's why
in the beginning our our playset that
came with the starter pack was supposed
to be all about episodes one through
three when we talked to lucasfilm about
how much we wanted ahsoka inside of the
game they had said well in order to get
clone wars the animated series kind of
mixing with the fiction of episodes one
through three because it's a little bit
of a different time frame we're gonna
have to do an original story so the uh
the playset that comes with the starter
pack uh is based on kind of that i
always go it's based on episodes one
through three you know the clone wars
era it's real general enough to cover
everything that's amazing that they
allowed you to create a license to do
that actually well it's you know they're
they have a story franchise team there
at lucasfilm and we worked very very
closely with them and of course our
talented writers at avalanche you know
do a draft of the script and then what
happens is they come and take a look at
like yes yes no no this wouldn't happen
this character would never do this and
you know there's a whole big back and
forth um it's not canon according to the
new franchise timeline uh but at the
same time it is it is an original story
that's a lot of fun fact none of the
games are canon i believe that's the
lucasfilm guys yeah the the new rules
yeah and do you guys find like uh taking
sort of the third swing at this as well
that they're more receptive to your
ideas because you you've kind of proven
over the past two games that this is
something that really works
that's a really interesting question
danny i think what we're seeing
is
the partners that we've worked with for
a long time in the past
know that our our team cares about
their characters and the content and
honoring that um
in a way that the filmmakers or the
content creators would appreciate and so
some of our older partners that we've
worked with like pixar especially and as
well as the team at um uh disney
did nice sean right on the live stream
uh disney feature animation or disney
animation series is called and parks and
resorts they know they're they're
they're more open with us taking more
creative lessons because we've been
working with them for so long yeah um
the team at marvel we did a whole bunch
with last year
and uh you know working with them this
year they're like okay we get what
infinity is now we kind of understand
but at first i mean you have to imagine
we kind of come in there and it's not
like a slam dunk that we're going to be
able to work on
star wars even though the company
acquired lucasfilm we have to convince
all the powers that be that it's the
right thing to do for their franchise
because presumably everyone involved in
the company would be clown bringing to
make something with star wars yeah right
exactly just
not only that i mean companies like
lucasfilm for a long time have had
existing licensing deals with other
great game developers for other
different great games so why would i put
it in infinity when i know that i've had
this so
um that's why we work so hard to to do
everything we can to increase the
quality of the overall experience so we
brought on studios like ninja theory i
mentioned earlier and and sumo digital
these guys that are kind of really
really great at what they do
in order for us to create an experience
for star wars that span the entire saga
so it's not only episodes one through
three it's not only clone wars it's not
only the star wars rebels animate series
it's not only episodes four through six
it's also episode seven i mean there's
tons of characters and tons of content
let's have a look at them because the
other aspect of this of course is the
physical yeah the the toys and then
what's funny here if you guys can see so
i told sean to bring hulkbuster because
uh i knew our team is very very proud of
this but like let's talk about the star
wars characters first before we go into
how cool
so um shawn would you uh did you clip
your nails who's got the nicest hands
because not me no no yes
those are you bite your nails delicious
oh so delicious i bite my nails too but
uh all right well sean works for me so
we'll make him hand model absolutely so
start with the classics oh okay i want
you to pitch this live here to danny and
i thanks that's always good you know
review season here is uh in october so
yeah
go ahead sean do it should have said no
it seems like a good time to uh to be
doing this right so reviews are coming
up so this will be good uh this is luke
skywalker
uh yeah
you'll know him from classics as star
wars or now the new hope yeah episode
four
um
and he has a lightsaber great
perfect 10 out of 10 from me
loved it so now this star trek that
you're talking about is it uh is there
more than just one movie there are
actually three uh three movies in this
play set rise against empire gene
robinson
yeah gene roddenberry did a lot of work
are we gonna get trouble for that
yeah no this is luke skywalker
who is awesome and played by mark hamill
who also has done a lot of great voice
over in video games um although we did
not
awkwardly now
right well he was a little bit busy at
the time when we were working on this so
luke skywalker comes with which playset
rise against the empire okay when does
that come out that comes out
next week it's right here danny's
holding it it's got princess leia as
well september 28th awkward all courses
29th 29th thank you would have been
important thing to tell us in the car
joy i'm kidding oh i don't know what's
your name i meant joy from inside out
sorry
also uh that star here
yeah and then uh who's the other
character sean that we have here this is
princess leia she also comes with the
rise against the uh empire place uh-huh
uh she's a ranged fighter okay so she
she has a gun
okay
that's a blaster
no guns and i had a blaster we're
playing with her last night in disney
infinity did you know
i said that's pretty good i sound like a
pitch man
i don't know it's okay you guys you guys
can all uh i'll join in here now she's
got a pretty cool special move doesn't
she sean can you tell us about it no
okay i can so she's got a super move
that um summons r2d2
to her aid and then uh also once you
unlock all the different combos for her
her final move in her combo we can
actually show we should show it right
yeah let's show it yeah okay
she's right here i gotta find some
enemies
next you're going to turn to luke
skywalker because we took him off here
we go look you're actually seeing it
happen right now bam
boom
loading
four minutes and 55 seconds oh this is
horrible look at that what's horrible i
gotta find the enemies you gotta find
well thankfully disney infinity 3.0
comes with a new feature a map
in the bottom left-hand corner which
should be able to show you various
things like new missions as well as
enemies see all i'd be doing is going
around picking up all those critters and
throwing them and that's completely
acceptable that's one of my favorite
things to do in this game and then punt
them
you can punt them yeah you can punch
them
yeah do a double jump and then and then
hit throw oh my god and then they'll
punt them you guys have thought of
everything okay there we go so sean i
know it's hard to um play and talk at
the same time but
explain to everyone what you're doing
i'm getting shot by an ats team i'm
dying mostly that's what i'm doing
you're poor level 20 leia this is
supposed to
yeah if you wanted to jump in wait are
we are we supposed to play together can
you play together danny will you play
this is your opponent can i can i is
this as a sony star wars card yeah i
like stars characters all right i'll
play this challenge we're getting
do you want chewie yeah done chewie yet
i will put chewie on so long as we can
cut back to danny's face and watch him
do a chewbacca roar okay i think that
that's that's okay right can we do that
no yeah all right here we go what's
wrong buddy i'm afraid there's gonna be
an animated gif here i should be in
there but let's hear your chewbacca roar
danny
that's good all right yeah you kind of
sounded like a fish person but
i think chewie's roar is more like
i preferred mine okay fine all right i'm
in you can also be do uh share share
ownership i have that the same thing
with my ex-wife and my kids
whoa i'm not even gonna unpack that
where are you at i gotta i gotta use the
map to find him he's over there
all right i'm coming for you wait no
that sounds like it's han solo and
chewbacca
taking on atsts
got that going the wrong way it's this
way right yeah it is
if we had some sort of mode of transport
around here is there one can i use that
millennium no they're not they'll fly
you into space god damn it but it's a
great time to transition and also say
disney infinity features open world
space flight oh my god so it's like uh
it's likely dangerous it's uh yeah maybe
maybe not star citizen or i should say
more accessible
for a wider audience well ikea furniture
is more accessible
i think dangerous
uh all right i'm coming i'm coming to
help follow the trail of coins there's
lando
yeah go to the no no go to the yellow
thing
we're watching in real time danny's 80d
kicking in
there you go 80dd and ocd it's all it's
the perfect combination so they have a
little area of effect attack they're
doing i'm going to go melee this guy
ah
beat you up in my crossbow finisher
cause i'm chewy do the finisher oh did i
do it no no you took him down
oh god
but next time you do that if you so if
you do the timing correctly you can do a
finisher which is like a big
i just stole all this danny's on the
right and shawn's on the left
eat it
so is this skill tree all
of all the abilities been unlocked yeah
yeah chewy oh god i've pulled aggro now
accidentally oh look he's kicking that
little thing hey dairy
little critter
look at him he's just destroying him
this is not cool
what he's doing now let me let me have a
quick little john can i go into my skill
tree here yeah look you can actually
yeah go uh hit circle or go back
uh hit options again option there we go
there you go skill tree
is it all knocked oh yeah look at that
there's the first one chewbacca's gambit
this is his like special yeah ability
stuff and then the melee skills it says
negative 50 if anyone's wondering
because we use like they have a special
developer power disc that like auto
levels characters
uh and when you do that it bugs out and
shows a negative that's how we know if
anyone ever sends us a message that
they've cheated right
do you have to have that like special
special
disc tied to your like person at all no
no no like one of my one of my guys yeah
but not uh
not for for actually playing the game
come on dot dot i'm going to try and
finish in this one
howie yeah get in there
and hop in yeah get in square square
there you go great that's what's about
oh my god there's nothing scarier than
danny o'dwyer in an atst oh my this is
my star wars fantasies are happening
right now
where am i going to go
careful that'll be a trap well it's not
set well it would normally be a trap
what do you got on your hands what's
that thing
a little forest crater crater critter
i'm gonna shoot you in your forest
critter how about that you slammed it
down the ground
oh man i can jump in this thing really i
love it
there's that creative license again yeah
well no that's the toy version of it oh
yeah of course mission failed i never
should fail i still had fun i still have
fun okay let's have a look at some of
the other um models okay while we're
here as well though because i do really
like the detail on these things do you
yeah that's darth vader
show everyone your hand bitten nails as
you hand model
so that's uh
so that's darth vader he's grabbing my
finger thinking why do you bite your
nails
and so he's uh he's
based off of uh
actually inspired by i should say um the
old macquarie design for for vader uh
and then we've also got um this is kanan
from star wars rebels which is uh a new
animated series that's out right now
this is sabine she's also from star wars
rebels
uh ezra and then zeb
um so what's cool about kanan is that i
thought he was using a different finger
for a second there
that would not be
not past disney's no of course not can
you imagine someone's like uh has anyone
seen the pose for zip
uh but anyway what's cool about kanan is
that he's got a lightsaber and also uses
a blaster so it's a little bit
dante-esque in terms of juggling and
things that he's can do
sabine um has a blaster but she also
uses a whole bunch of different paint
grenades um zeb
is primarily a melee fighter but one
thing that's cool about him is that
inside the toy box he's got wall crawl
abilities so definitely go check him out
sorry about that i know you cut to the
up close shot there right as i moved it
away okay if i do it again i won't i
won't
there it is it's beautiful thing i think
i killed him about 500 times in halo
yeah
actually so this character when i fun
backstory this character if you look at
any of the old macquarie designs for
chewbacca yeah that's exactly what the
story looks like so i'm not like any
spoiler any star wars big star wars fan
knows this but it's really cool to see
um actually at gamescom they had this um
this great star wars exhibit that i went
to and you can actually see chewbacca
and this zeb character next to each
other and some of the original designs
that they evolved so
and then yeah just like in terms of
detail too i mean it's just our team
really really prides on if you want to
come in close like trying to make these
not only like kind of fun figures but
then also have a ton of detail and ezra
right here actually has you know marks
on uh on his face um that's part of the
fiction of the character if i keep it
there um like even sabine another
character from star wars rebels when you
get in close you actually see how her
armor's worn
and then like you know the figures
themselves instead of like kind of doing
it the
the
less expensive way i'll say and and
painting these um these are actually all
individual pieces because we want to
make sure that like for for core gamers
like like me and you um that we'd be
proud to own these put them on our desk
but then also at the same time they're
fun to play with and they're and they're
fun to check out inside of the game yeah
they do feel like good quality they also
feel like you can chuck them around and
they won't like so that's the pieces so
but this one this is this one
so this is the hulk monster here i
thought that this base would have to be
like twice as big or something
so yeah that's our uh hulkbuster figure
so we've announced that character but
that's probably the one that we've done
that has the most detail um that we have
uh put into a figure yet uh and like
when you kind of hold them and feel them
you can feel the different grooves and
all the different things that we've done
so
it's all uh it's all done by our team at
avalanche software
and what's fun is that you know five
years ago none of us knew anything about
making making toys
we just watched a game developer dorks
this is my favorite one though that's
sadness i brought this from home this is
my favorite one oh look at that she's
tiny do you want to um load up a like or
should we share some more rise
what do you guys want to see can we is
there a chat can we see the chat
yeah we can ask the chat i got the chat
yeah they want we can show more of rise
against the empire let's do let's do one
more piece of writing okay yeah there's
so many different missions in there and
it is some of the newer stuff so tell me
about some of your experiences with
sadness uh i feel like this is like a
pretty intimate conversation i started
with leia right yeah i had this sadness
how did you get this weight so how did
you get the sadness i guess i think i
got the sad i think i got the sadness
from you at e3 really i think i got the
sadness for you d3 because you gave us a
bunch to give away and there was one of
them that was like busted so i was like
oh i'll take that and i hadn't seen the
movie yet okay and i was like right here
we go yes yeah and so i had this thing
actually no i gave it to my girlfriend i
was like there they go yeah and we had
it up on top of a shelf in the house and
i totally forgot and i was playing this
uh again last night uh with leia and she
was like oh we tried because she owns
disney infinity on we the first one okay
my girlfriend does she was like oh have
you tried sadness yet and i was like no
i don't have it she was like oh no that
thing down i was like nah that doesn't
work that's like a yeah i totally forgot
this thing existed i was like
and she brings it over and so i'm like
oh god yeah sorry this actually is the
same thing so i popped it in um
and uh
yeah then i i realized that she throws
like sadness bubbles at people do you
really like that have you done her uh
have you done her her block and dodge
yet i've done no okay wait we'll we'll
show that for okay let's see but based
so she's actually voiced in our game by
phil smith the the actress that um
played her inside of the film and
there's lots of like random dialogue
that happens yeah like i was doing at my
house and she was like she bumped into
somebody and said something yeah that's
something that's a lot of fun um when we
get the voice actors in there to uh
record their lines um the team that the
disney character voices that does all
the recording for us they'll let them
freestyle uh and say like you know oh
the the famous example of this is sarah
silberman right who um reprised her role
for infinity as vanellope von schweitz
from wreck-it ralph so when you actually
have vanellope von schweitz inside the
toy box there's a whole bunch of
original sarah silverman lines that she
says as vanellope when she runs into
jack sparrow oh that's when she runs
into mr incredible and so
it's fun to write those things because
you actually then can actually have this
fun dialogue between you know what would
happen when thor meets darth vader and
there's all this kind of fun writing
that that happens like you experienced
yeah and i was i was playing through the
the combat i guess the first like combat
tutorial part in like nightmare before
christmas land while that music's
playing and there's a bunch of like
weird aladdin people coming towards me
and i'm sadness like throwing
it's sadness balls but or memory quorum
everything's but to me they're just like
throwing tears like someone's like take
that leg
you jerk holes yeah that's a good way to
put it awesome yeah so that's um for for
those of you that don't know where
danny's talking about is is our motive
play that's called the toy box yeah
which we'll show you yeah that's where
all the characters mash up and you can
build levels inside of there you can
download new toy boxes designed by
people um design your own upload them
and we actually do a weekly show where
we highlight the top five coolest
designs that are coming in the community
and then make them available for people
to download for free yeah we'll get into
it later i was surprised how deep some
of that stuff actually gets but what are
we looking at here this is another
aspect this is your classic
your classic scene right that everybody
wants to play
uh my friend actually
he bought the saga pack and he was
saying he loved playing this with this
kid he was playing it colorful this kid
his kid is not has never actually
watched any of the originals oh cool but
just clone wars and he was just having a
blast so it was crazy you know when we
talked to lucasfilm about
you know how to do episodes four through
six and how we wanted to to realize it
inside the game they had said
video games end up being
uh one of the ways that a lot of kids
are introduced to star wars as a
franchise which is why it's so important
for your rise against the empire place
that to really feel like it's true to
property to feature all these vehicles
and all these different characters
i i guess i would never have expected
that the gateway would be that would be
video games yeah i guess it's a way to
that you'd it's sort of a way that you
you be you get like a very personal
relationship with these franchises
because when you're playing something
yourself you feel more invested true
everything that's going on yeah you're
right it's like you and sadness have a
special exactly yeah that's one of the
many reasons me and samus are very
special
the toy part is super funny too like my
my son he's very young he hasn't watched
the originals other than a couple times
to try to force it on
but i got the uh
you mean when he really wanted to enjoy
the experience
my jedi handwave
he loves rebels i absolutely love him
yeah that's a 30-minute show right and
like he doesn't want to sit through like
talking yeah but uh but now he walks
around the house going daddy where's the
millennium falcon because i bought the
uh the millennium falcon like remote
control unit and so he he's like totally
into it yeah it's funny i i saw online
like we were catching some heat from
people like oh well to play the star
wars you really want to play you have to
pick up the starter pack and the thing
is like remember this game is is
primarily intended for kids and family
and kids grew up with episodes one
through three and the clone wars
animated series yeah they didn't grow up
with episodes four through six that's
like that's like the tng fans being told
watch the old ones or like some of them
will but like a lot of most right
if you were gonna put out yeah if you
were gonna put out a game like that
right now that was aimed at a younger
audience right you would put out
whatever the most relevant content is
for that audience the the funny the
anecdotal story was the team that works
on club penguin yeah which also disney
disney owns and operates um they threw a
star wars party right after the
acquisition happened and uh so all the
penguins are you know dressed up as
different characters and the kids were
going where's anakin where's darth maul
really like because they weren't
familiar with characters from four
through six so um that's why we ended up
in case you was wondering that's why we
ended up putting um our our twilight or
the republic play set inside of that
starter pack wow yeah it's kind of it's
kind of fun to be able to you know peek
behind the curtain of all the different
brand rules and q scores of characters
and why is jar jar so popular it must be
because people don't like them right
it's like no actually kids love jar jar
as a character what you know like as an
adult and as a huge star wars fan
hearing all that stuff it's it's wild
any walks in in this game yeah there's
ewoks in uh in the end section someone's
like can you add wicket to the game most
of the messages i'm getting now on like
twitter and instagram i posted a photo
the other day
uh with um uh
uh christy uh why am i forgetting this
right now
um
uh anyway i posted like i'm posting
photos on on instagram now and people
are responding with
uh hey cool photo can you please add
indiana jones to the game
like characters have nothing to do with
you know the photo yeah what's what's
the because last year like i said i did
hand you about the star wars stuff but
uh what's what's on the what's next on
the list people are asking for hi wicked
really yeah wicked is one of them i'm a
theater fan but i would have forgotten
about that
and like i've seen labyrinth you know
that's one of the things that i found so
crazy when i was playing this the toy
box stuff was just how
wide the net is on disney properties
it's like i was scrooge mcduck popping
up and like all that stuff
yeah of course in the nightmare before
christmas and being like oh yeah of
course yeah then like star wars stuff
pops in and like old cartoons i've
forgotten about as well as i said to uh
as i said to the game and former guys
our bench is deep bro
we've uh when you take a look at i mean
just all of the ip across the company
it's um it's crazy we had gus the field
goal kicking mule in the game last year
from uh from the gus film the condor man
also killed connor man are you familiar
with condor man released the same year
as star wars so it was oh really yeah it
had a had a little bit of a challenge
there but um it was a funny movie about
uh about a guy that basically had
created wings you have to see it anyway
i think i didn't won an oscar last year
we had put uh condor man's wings inside
of the game okay and um it was funny
because it took a lot of work with legal
because we started working on it and
we're like we just want to make sure
we've got legal clearance here to do
this and they said geez you know no one
was thinking about the interactive
rights for condorman film in 1979 and
now you guys are trying to do this but
we end up working through it and it
plays the music from the film too which
is which is famous
everyone knows and loves right
a lot of people asking uh to see uh
hulkbuster uh bob jones uh 1980 and a
couple of other ones some we can show
gabrielle uh we should do that we should
just we shoot some two-player toy box
yeah
two-player
uh it can be yeah awesome and so right
now what shawn's gonna go into is the
toy box hub so this is kind of a new
thing that our team has put into the
game this year the thing with the toy
box was
um
for those of you that don't know you can
you know build and create it's kind of
like minecraft with with disney
characters and lots of different
mechanics in terms of what our
characters can do
which i think separates it from from
minecraft but be that as it may
when we had originally put it out there
we were like here's a blank slate create
whatever you can imagine and there's
certain players that you know gravitated
towards this and like oh look at this
great stuff that i can make and there
are certain players that are intimidated
right
i say it's you can't put a piece of
paper
and some pencils in front of anyone and
say hey just go ahead and start drawing
yeah some people are like i don't know
what to draw i'm not a good artist you
know that kind of thing so we created
this toy box hub mode that basically
functions as a way for players to get
familiar with infinity all the different
things you can do inside of infinity and
some of the great things that you can
build so after these agrabah guards stop
attacking han solo
we'll show you kind of some of this some
of this fun i thought this was a massive
improvement um in terms of accessibility
thanks man uh all the sort of vo stuff
um was really good like not too much
information but just enough to sort of
like let you and probably as well
younger audiences know what to do and
where to go and whatnot and the fact
that it's sort of split up into like
different areas like you've got your
house and you've got your combat sort of
sector the farming area
um this main street usa is a lot of fun
too
uh and the funny thing is yeah that's
flynn's arcade from tron so that's
actually where you go when you're
connected online to be um randomly
matched against humans in um various toy
boxes and toy box games and there's like
the el capitan theater so
in los angeles disney owns this famous
movie theater called the el capitan
theater and you can go inside of there
and watch the latest episode of toy box
tv which is the the web series that we
have or like hey this is the cool stuff
that the community's made this week
check it out download it so when you go
inside of it you can um you know we've
got like different posters that
celebrate our user community and what
they've made does that mean all your
videos of you were in there as well yes
yeah that's so ridiculous all right next
we got to get a like a little uh john
vanyaki
sidekick yeah
yeah so everyone can just yeah attack
him i'm sure
yeah scrooge mcduck's right there and
there's like the the um
there's the uh the the bears from the
park i mean there's just so much fun
sorry little barbershop who's the yellow
he looks like like vault boy yeah who is
that guy let me see who he is he's just
like he's a janitor
cleaning up still a little cleaning
what's going on over there it's a crazy
job the way we want it
it's a part of the racetrack
that guy's balloon is that's dangerously
large that one of the pink elephants
from dumbo that might be what that is
yeah that's one of my favorite things to
do so far is like running around and
trying to figure out who certain people
are because you're like there's like a
there's like a shadow in my memory of
who you are but i'm i can't exactly
piece it together those are zerg bats
from toy story
who's that guy
oh i think that's one of the guards from
who is from uh rapunzel uh tango tango
oh yeah
that's the omnidroid from the
incredibles
yeah i mean this is totally the ultimate
mashup right
uh you can spawn stuff in here as well
and mess about and yeah
hop into some of that stuff and actually
something that's really fun it's it's
you have to meet certain criteria or
there's jabba's palace in the background
which is really awkward with the disney
castle yeah yeah
but there's
there's
there's events now that happen inside
the toy box as well so depending on
if you meet the right criteria or not
like yesterday we were randomly playing
and all of a sudden two gigantic star
destroyers flew over the top of the toy
box and then launched a crazy assault
with tie fighters and so like as you're
kind of just running around here doing
different things and exploring the hub
um certain things will happen there's
parades too that happen just like at the
park so yeah it's kind of fun just to
explore and see what happens
yeah wander over this way this is into
the the next this is the night before
you're talking about right yeah there
was full of aladdin people freaking the
goddamn hell out this is like the sort
of combati tutorial place where yeah
right right here let's put on hulkbuster
oh yeah let's do it as the gamespot
users had uh requested
here we go
boom i thought you're going to jump in
you want me to jump in you can all right
can i jump in yeah here you go can i
jump in with sadness yeah yeah
get my sadness in there
danny
playing a sadness
loading into the center you're not
signed on the ps4 don't care about psn
my sadness stats can stay on my
home shed this toy
boom
what are you doing sweet no
no you're not sure
no
okay now run over there yo what's up
look at that sadness
i could go help i could go over here and
do some farming or check out my water
look at this
i'd probably go help can i get the i saw
someone post um hulk doing farming
yeah my favorite
there are certain characters that are
really funny in the toy box to see them
doing somebody's like darth vader
farming right or drax the destroyer
right from guardians of the girls
tasks yeah exactly if i'm right i can
hop on one of these as a mount right yes
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna come help in a
second
i wanna that's the best i thought we
were doing farming so i was gonna come
over here
you could also fly over there what's up
hop on yeah i love you can still double
jump
i can still throw my tears at you
ate my sadness
looks like there's a fight brewing here
between hulkbuster and sadness
you know just like in that movie inside
out
oh my godness
where should we go oh here wait check
this out this danny jump off of it what
you do but yeah hit circle i think it is
okay now i want you to hold down circle
okay and then so this is how you block
and then check out yeah right which is
her block is like no
so then if you if you use the um use the
left analog to dodge and she actually
does her her role from the film like
have you seen inside
when she's like well i just want to stay
here
it's funny when you have like a crazy
all-out battle with like hulkbuster just
wrecking shop and sadness rolling around
throwing
oh i'll just be here yeah
oh my goodness man what is
oh what oh what happened why'd you do
that [ __ ] she makes i was saving her
ah i've headbutt you with my sadness
and all this is just this is just like
in the hub area yeah from this kind of
playing around and in this sub-area
though you can you can launch into
different
like do you have a special yeah you can
do you have our special disc yes i do
wait do wait you wanted the grind you
don't want the grind okay you don't want
to level up sadness i don't want op
sadness i need to earn it although it
does it doesn't retain on the toy does
it yeah it does oh it does it writes the
toyota oh man maybe i didn't do it
yesterday because i had her up to like
level five yesterday well since you did
share ownership so we
we're different than than the other guys
so what we do is we want it so one
family will be able to buy one toy and
then share it between brothers and
sisters so depending on which profile is
signed in it creates basically a slot on
that profile that has what that
character's level is which is whether
it's a share ownership or plays guest so
okay so so basically i'm like playing
with sean's kind of one yeah so this is
this is shawn's ps4 that we've brought
here
on his profile he had never loaded
sadness before
danny came over brought his sadness toy
and then and rather than play as a guest
which would be danny's sadness
sean now shares ownership and a sadness
profile exists
and that is hulkbuster flying a x-wing
so you can go up and talk to these folks
and they'll like give you missions as
well yeah hop in here like
if i jump into this little this is the
combat area right yeah you guys want to
go in there yeah sure yeah jump in there
try one of these things out so then
which one do you want to do
which one's which one's your favorite
um game great is that tron well they go
yeah you could go into that one they um
they escalate in difficulty so sean will
you accept the invite yeah
yeah come play with me in tron
i like it what is that noise it sounds
like portillo's
still not the game
is it sorry yeah it was okay it was it
was the mainstream oh it was the game
you're talking about
the game you've been shopping for years
yeah you're pretty tired man i had never
uh i don't think i'd heard that one
that uh that pizza such as the amount of
content in disney infinity
there's like so this is crazy right
there's like over
6 000 virtual toys oh wow that you can
play with inside of here and you
but if you can imagine the amount of
work it is because all of it's carried
forward from the first one to this one
right for our our programmers at
avalanche right to just
the amount of assets and the amount of
check-ins that are happening across the
eight different studios that we have
working on infinity it's uh it's this is
a pretty sophisticated game for for all
intents and purposes being a kids game
oh
look at this look at this picture
hey
i can pick you up what
video games please drop me ah
wait here but do the do the drop kick so
pick them up
oh and then i can yes jump square to
pick up yeah let's go
and then double jump and then hit there
you go
classic classic don't hit me back
okay
otherwise you're gonna have to roll
yeah i'm gonna have to do my little
you just did the super
he's launching all of those missiles out
not me
my goodness all right someone go and
pick up a mission and do the uh
you're right there all right where's the
mission at he goes charmed i'm sure
uh right over where the blue exclamation
point is
no it's a little bit further you're left
there oh sorry look at the map yeah it's
a little tron guy hey what's going on
tron man
hello user welcome to slingshot step on
the challenge maker to begin and then
enter the slingshot to travel in the
grid
search of fun so for everyone that's
watching yes this is the hub mode but
this is all built using our toy box
builder and assets and things like that
so people can do this as well this is
yeah exactly when you get into our
community you start downloading the
things that people are creating this is
the type of
uh user-generated content people are
making um and it's cool because infiniti
is the first time where people can use
all of these incredible characters
across disney marvel pixar and star wars
to build
their own stories and in their own games
oh
all right where's my one there
all right here we go
so then what you want to do here yeah is
you're going to use the analog stick to
pull back
and then launch the slingshot and then
yeah try to hit the the
tetris pieces
and there's also uh there's yeah you're
gonna see little blue guys there there
you go
there you go nice
and this is the type of games that
people can make themselves
yeah yeah exactly
oh come on
mine's broke
mine is my
that's what i do all the time
speaking no um one shawn actually has a
really really exciting thing to announce
oh my god he has uh he submitted
this morning yeah the um ios and android
version for tablets and for phones
disney infinity 3.0
so um hopefully that's going to come out
at the end of the month um
and uh it is the toybox experience that
you're seeing right here
um and you can play it by you can
microtransact characters digitally if
you want to
download obviously toy boxes for free
and so you can play tons of games like
this is there any crossovers with the
toys that you own in that one at all yes
so every one of our figures that
you purchase comes with a web code card
okay and then you can type that in the
disney infinity website yes and then
it'll honor the ownership of that
physical toy on the digital platforms
and these are going for the close ones
also the toy box toys that you unlock on
console will be recognized when you go
on to the mobile version as well
excellent so if you make a level on the
on ps4 and you want to work on it while
you're you know on the train going to
work or you know on vacation you can
totally do that sweet yeah coming out of
you're hoping the end of this month yeah
you the submission process on yeah yeah
it's pretty it's pretty archaic i think
it's uh
so yeah we're really what we're excited
about it's it's what's fun about it is
that it's not like a
we didn't you know we
we didn't go off and create a totally
separate version of infinity what we did
was create one that we thought was at
the same level of quality as what we do
on console
and so it is the it is the full toy box
experience it's not like an endless
runner that's called infinity
like i guess that's what i was trying
but you could probably make an endless
runner inside inside yeah actually we
did that last year
uh we did with dash it was kind of fun
uh what's your favorite level that's in
uh 3.0 what's your favorite sort of like
experience you go back to um
that i like to do i actually like
just playing around in a
a small toy box
that um is procedurally generated by the
computer i think what people have the
most fun doing
is exploring
what you can actually do inside of the
game and so this this will get a little
bit heady
but the amount of mechanics that are
inside of infinity in terms of what
characters can do right characters can
walk they can run they can jump they can
double jump they can leg hang they can
side saddle they can fire a blaster they
can wield the lightsaber they can ride
on a mount they can fly a ship they can
they can they can i mean there's so many
different things you can do inside of
infinity that exploring hey what happens
if
and um
what happens when you know and all these
different scenarios that that players
create when they're playing inside of
infinity i think is is really part of
the charm uh adam boyce who works at
sony you know adam adam called me on the
phone he said
my kids aren't playing the playsets
they're inside of the toy box and
they're running around just throwing
each other off of cliffs and giggling
uncontrollably and they've been doing
this for five hours and so it's like
it's wild it's like it's okay to play
you know as adults we we keep on going
back to hey i need a structured gameplay
experience what are my objectives yeah
and while we have that inside of here we
also have just the ability to kind of
explore and play however you want to
which i think is it's fun and unique in
the game space oh my goodness
you guys tied dead he's
tied i kept it close did you know you i
did what i could no you didn't
uh that's it disney infinity 2.0 disney
infinity 3.0 out now
64.99 starter pack 6 for 4.99 for the
starter box cheaper than any competition
and comes with two toys and uh you know
everything you need to get started and
then rise against the empire on the 29th
34.99 that's so it's sold separately
yeah but a lot of fun and would love to
hear from everyone that's watching what
they think about it when they play and
if they think it's very good
are you going to review it probably i'm
not going to review it you're not going
to didn't we already reviewed it didn't
randy already reviewed but you guys
haven't reviewed the playsets oh i don't
know i'm wondering if people are going
to start doing i think i feel like
mean i've seen it pop up from different
outlets already reviewing the rise
against the empire i mean we reviewed
the taken king
right or we are in the process of
reviewing the king uh the problem is
when you do this in the middle of crazy
review season i know definitely january
yeah sorry sorry but we'll see i'll ask
peter brown
we'll get an answer to that one and of
course we're giving away a bunch of
these uh we're doing so via the
wonderful method of twitter so if you
head over to at gamespot on twitter
there should be a tweet there make sure
you retweet it uh you'll be in for a
chance to win one of the rise against
the empire playset uh that was north
america only though sadly um so uh yeah
sorry about that we could give you some
ones actually they're they are agnostic
so that will work it will work we can't
give it away oh right we have that same
problem illegally legal right it was
worse i lived in ireland right games by
uk couldn't send prizes to ireland
because it was too legal so i know so we
uh yeah we have that exact same thing
and people are asking us all the time
like why is everything in north america
why is everything in north america and
we're like you know because we hate the
rest of the world no yeah not at all
we have to figure that we have to figure
out a point of contact on our european
team that can start doing all this kind
of stuff because that's a you know it's
a game worldwide and last things uh here
we got the uh the uh powerdisk pack what
are these bad boys so i see these in
target all the time right and and we
used to do them before as we sell them
in blind packs like trading cards yes
you didn't know you were getting yeah so
and then all of our consumers complained
and we pride ourselves on listening to
our community so we put them now
invisible packs so you know what you're
getting um so this one is going to
launch in conjunction with the rise
against the empire playset um and it
comes with four discs it's 9.99 so we
used to do two discs for 4.99 in a blind
pack now we do four discs you know what
you're getting for 9.99 so that was the
the math going on there but it comes
with a costume change disc for princess
leia as well as one for luke
it comes with a y-wing vehicle that you
can play with inside your toy box and
slave one
which is boba fett ship so
be sure to check this out it's a lot of
fun and of course any character across
all of infinity can play with these
ships which is great fun to see you know
hulkbuster flying around and slave one
and that kind of not tied to any
playsets or people around yeah yeah yeah
exactly awesome gentlemen johnny sean
thank you so much for going on thank you
for having us and thanks everyone for
watching yeah thanks to everyone for
watching thanks to eric tay and joshua
in production ready for setting this
whole thing up and we'll be back right
here on gamespot.com for more in
airplanes so make sure you hit that add
button if you're watching on youtube
gaming uh hit follow if you're on twitch
and if you're on gamespot how you doing
we've got a bunch more stuff coming up
on the site today so stick around uh
we'll see you next time so take care bye
guys
you